fairies mythical creatures and
fantastical figures cosplayers bring
characters to life from manga comics
anime cartoons & fantasy stories in the
role of the Guardian albedo from the
Japanese anime overlord
twenty-six-year-old Lisa aldenham
wanders through the halls of the Leipzig
Book Fair where the manga comic
convention is being held Oh Steve kind
of like when you walk through a city
like this people look at you like you're
weird who needs that at a convention you
meet people with the same hobby who like
to walk around in cosplay and watch the
same series and read the same manga the
optic nice day who put on my glasses
who's your all suppose in Germany alone
about 15,000 cosplayers regularly take
on such roles millions of people around
the world love mangoes animes and comics
the theme is especially active in Japan
and the United States and Europe
mangas have fascinated Lisa since her
childhood she began cosplaying eight
years ago she designs the costumes
herself a precondition for being taken
seriously in the scene she taught
herself to turn a picture in an anime
into a sketch and then into a sewing
pattern she has produced about 50
cosplay outfits by now some are finished
within a day others like the one she's
working on here take several months does
his head coach with you have also learnt
the challenge in cosplays that you have
to design and create something that
never existed before that's the
attraction to hear others say oh that
looks fantastic I want to make one too
I've created something I can be proud of
I've put lots of work time and money
into this it's a hobby that demands
imagination and creativity walkman few
fantasy and creativity cosplay is also
an expensive hobby costumes often
require hundreds of euros to make
accessories like a pair of wings take a
lot of work Lisa luda gnomes real name
is Lisa Hochstein and she works as a
medical technician for her hobby she's
always experimenting with new materials
for example thermoplastic fabric when
it's heated it can be turned into any
shape desired the vista toot of armor
with all its individual pieces is Lisa's
most difficult project so far sapphic
will start something new you consider
all the details sometimes you think I
wish I hadn't started this but when
you're finished you're glad you did it
if you had not released as mollusca shop
had a small but effective detail is the
finishing touch to this cosplay outfit
colored contact lenses
practice is a snitch reiner it's not
really practical you have trade-offs you
have to walk around for a day with a
strand of hair in your face but you do
it for a convention or for photos nobody
said it was easy back at the leipzig
book fair Lisa walks through the
exhibition as the Guardian albedo she
comes to the book fair dressed in a
different costume every day photos of
each costume are crucial Jennifer Mashti
specializes in cosplay photography and
when I cosplay hotness if you have a
cosplay outfit you want to show it to
everyone so ultimately the completed
processed photograph you upload is
extremely important to the cosplayer
that's the only way to display your
costume see Scalia's a costume display
for Lisa laudanum the manga comic
convention at the leipzig book fair is
the highlight of the year especially
because of the recognition she gets from
fans that loan when I would look during
word for my work is that other people
who know the series recognize the
costume it's a relatively unknown series
and so when someone says I know that
costume I know I've done my duty
cosplayers use lots of imagination to
bring the fantasy worlds of mangas and
animes to life at least for a day